hey guys it's alanna I'm Harry James
come at the 2k lounge and i'm just about
to play a vault let's go have a look so
evolved is an upcoming sci-fi co-op
first-person shooter there are four
player controlled hunters against some
kind of alien monster an error variety
monsters and a handful of closet even if
the forecast so there are more so I
played as Maggie who's a trapper though
there is also a tropical Griffin but
maggie has this dope kind of pet called
a trap jewel which is called Daisy and
it can track the monster
basically the hunt is a task with
killing the monster and a kind of plays
like a multiplayer bus fight just
imagine picking any bus fight in a game
then turning the mic on and having three
of your friends how to do it with you
but if you don't have a mic when you're
playing evolve it's not going to matter
that much because it's all inherently
tactical as a pen kind of system where
you can tell people exactly where you
are saw the monster pin all of the tools
you actually have access to a tactical
in themselves for example Maggie deploys
a dome she's called the trapper because
that Durham actually traps the enemy in
and it makes it really convenient for we
got the players to use their special
weapons to do a whole lot of damage
and all of the bosses have different
abilities just as the players do so
while you're trying to actually kill the
thing you're also needing to obey it at
the same time and get vantage points out
of the conscious repeatedly pummel your
attack you or you're going to die pretty
damn fast which is probably what a
jetpack comes in handy I actually use
this a lot so you have a jet pack which
means you can jump on the high of kind
of mount any things but you can also
evade taxes by using it running side to
side or backwards probably isn't going
to be that effective especially against
the Kraken ready but the one stone which
is also a planet controlled kind of has
to do the exact same thing it can eat
the various smaller creatures that are
across maps to get help or go into a
cocoon stage to a bowl and you really
don't want it to do that because that's
when it gets way too strong for you to
fight but when it is in that career mode
if you happen to find it it has no
shield so you can do a ton of damage
it's also constantly a race against time
you don't want it to evolve too far to
make it way too strong for you you don't
want to take too much damage and there
are also the power generators routing
the map that if it destroys them it wins
it honestly has to be one of the most
intense games that I've ever played
because while all of the classes
themselves like the four hunters are
quite balanced the monster is way way
stronger than you are it's challenging
its tactical and it puts so much
pressure on you
so I just finished playing evolved
hearing things on something that really
really surprised me about evolved is
actually that when the monster is near
you you kind of can lose it really
quickly because the maps are so big and
because there are so many obstacles in
your way you don't constantly know where
it is it can actually obeyed you and get
away and then feed to get more health
and regenerated shield so it adds this
whole extra dynamic to panicking about
finding it before it can get its health
back and a whole lot of team working
there as well it's crazy intense and I
am so so looking forward to deformities